i look pretty
hm
okay cardi b grammy winner
chart topper and mom of the year
because she just let her two-year-old
daughter give her a makeover
and it is the cutest thing you'll see
all day
is she's so cute i love her on wednesday
the whop rapper shared
this video of her little girl culture
using her face as a canvas
i look pretty
hmm
okay oh my god culture's tiny little
voice
is everything and we blessed man of
course the 28 year old rapper shares
culture with her husband offset
oh yes honey and it seems like little
culture has inherited her mama's passion
for glitz and glam back in july for her
second birthday
culture received her first hermes birken
bag from her famous parents
[Music]
wow
and while culture scored that coveted
pink designer bag
it seems she's gonna have to wait a bit
longer until she's allowed to listen to
her mom's risque lyrics
back in january cardi went live on
instagram
talking to her fans and dancing to her
hit track
[ __ ]
[Music]
but when her little girl walked into the
room cardi scrambled to turn the music
off
fast
[Music]
well that got people talking on social
media
with some calling out the rapper for
being hypocritical
so cardi hit back on twitter explaining
quote
i don't make music for kids i make music
for adults
so whether it's playing with makeup or
dressing up all
fancy cardi b and culture are one
adorable mother-daughter duo